Narrator: ALASKA'S INTERIOR
IS ITS HEARTLAND.
THE LARGE REGION,
WHICH IS BIGGER THAN TEXAS,
IS WILD AND UNDEVELOPED.
WINTERS HERE ARE BRUTAL.
Craig:
WINTERS ARE EXTREME.
WE NORMALLY GET 60 INCHES
OF SNOWFALL A YEAR.
50 BELOW IS NOT UNCOMMON.
Narrator: DURING THE DARK DAYS
OF WINTER,
THE 100,000 RESIDENTS
OF INTERIOR ALASKA
ARE FORCED TO LIGHT
AND HEAT THEIR HOMES
FAR MORE THAN PEOPLE
IN THE LOWER 48.
ENERGY REALLY IS A REQUIREMENT.
YOUR PIPES
CAN FREEZE IN RAPID ORDER
IF THERE'S NO HEAT SOURCE.
WITHOUT ENERGY,
LIVES CAN BE AT RISK.
Narrator: THIS REMOTE PART
OF THE STATE
IS ALSO HOME TO LARGE OPERATIONS
THAT REQUIRE LOTS
OF ENERGY YEAR ROUND.
SEVERAL INDUSTRIAL SITES,
SEVERAL GOLD MINES
AND MILITARY BASES.
Narrator: FEEDING THE BEAST
IN THE INTERIOR ISN'T EASY.
ALASKA RANKS THIRD
IN THE COUNTRY
IN THE MOST ENERGY
CONSUMED PER PERSON.
ALASKANS GO THROUGH
826 MILLION BTUs PER CAPITA.
THAT'S 2.5 TIMES
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
Narrator: MOST OF ALASKA
DEPENDS ON FOSSIL FUELS
TO ENDURE THE HARSH ENVIRONMENT.
MANY REMOTE TOWNS
SURVIVE OFF DIESEL GENERATORS.
BUT THE POWER GRID
IN INTERIOR ALASKA
BOASTS THE BIGGEST
CLEAN ENERGY MACHINE
IN THE WHOLE STATE.
IT STRETCHES
ACROSS 170 ACRES,
BOASTS 12 GIANT TURBINES
THAT STAND NEARLY
AS TALL AS BIG BEN,
AND SPORT 36 WHIRLING BLADES.
TIP TO TIP
IS ABOUT THE SAME SIZE
AS A FOOTBALL FIELD.
Narrator: THIS IS EVA CREEK,
ALASKA'S LARGEST
COMMERCIAL WIND FARM.
TO SEE THOSE WIND TURBINES
STANDING THERE,
THEY'RE MAGNIFICENT.
THE EVA CREEK WIND TURBINES
ARE BIG.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A REDWOOD?
THESE ARE THE SAME SIZE
OF AN AVERAGE SIZE REDWOOD.
JUST THE SOUND OF IT
WHEN IT'S IN FULL PRODUCTION
IS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
THEY'RE HUGE.
THEY SEEM LIKE A SKYSCRAPER.
Narrator: THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
THE TURBINES CREATE POWER
WHEN STRONG WINDS
TURN THE BLADES,
WHICH ARE CONNECTED
TO GENERATORS.
FROM THERE, IT TRAVELS DOWN
INTO WHAT WE CALL
A COLLECTION SYSTEM
AND THEN ONTO THE GRID.
Narrator: ALL 12 WIND TURBINES
CAN GENERATE UP TO 24.6
MEGAWATTS OF ELECTRICITY
TO HELP POWER
THE INTERIOR OF ALASKA.
THAT ADDS UP OVER THE COURSE
OF A YEAR.
THE WHOLE SITE
HAS PRODUCED ENOUGH
FOR 11,000 HOUSES
FOR A WHOLE YEAR.